Two young men started their journey in Bitcoin last year.
One worked 12 hours a day, staring at charts,
chasing every green candle.
Last night, a single 'Whale Trap' wiped out his entire account.
The other man?
He spent his evening with his family, sipped a
coffee, and woke up to a $5,000 profit.
The difference wasn't luck.
It was the system.
One was hunting; the other was defending.
Most traders fail because they think trading is
about 'buying.' It’s not.
It’s about not falling for the traps.
In the BTC market, you are being hunted by institutions.
Without a shield, your emotions become your worst enemy.
You feel the FOMO, you click buy, and the trap snaps.
Trap Defence BTC changes everything.
Our engine visualizes the invisible traps of the whales.
We teach you the most powerful skill in the world: the discipline to
do nothing 70 percent of the time.
When you finally move, you move with 90 percent certainty.
It’s high-resolution defense for a high-stakes market.
Don't be the trader who loses it all.
Be the one who stays protected.
Activate your defense protocol below.
Welcome to the Academy.